oui raconte leur vie leur job comment ça
se passe avec les enfants ce qui les
inquiète dans la nuque et de l'équipe i
sleeve beaucoup ce que je réalise avec
soin de laisser les gens à arrêter de
parler de politique entre eux est en
tout cas jamais de politique de fond
faire virer à droite ici
s'il ya une chose pendant les
consultations qui ressort le plus c'est
que peu importe qu'il la question de
l'éducation damart d'inserts constamment
et on sent vraiment une inquiétude
profonde
le manque de ressources pour les élèves
en difficulté l'état des écoles les taux
de décrochage
iphone dans les écoles de cuisine c'est
qu'on peut vraiment pas vraiment le
monde pendant pendant longtemps
contraints d'aller en profondeur en tant
qu en soirée avec eux estime avoir 200
personnes ce soit moi je la
responsabilité mais si vous désirez
apporter grand chose à voir le look les
marques les plus justes
ce qui nous frappe en premier c'est la
mobilisation le désir de plus en changer
comment permettrait tout le monde se
sont plaint pas pensé scandalisé
d'évaluer les élèves c'est pas tout le
monde qui tombe sur le magnifique sommes
découragés les gens vous avez parlé de
cours de philosophie dès le primaire
sont intéressantes de préciser quand on
parle de cours de philosophie on parle
pas de parler on each périscope les
enfants six ans mais bien de cours pour
apprendre par exemple l'esprit critique
fort en france tant que tel ce redonner
le projet à faire la politique
la curiosité
je suis à ma table si tu veux
ces bases fondatrices qui est y
retrouver certaines aubry déjà le droit
des gens plus perrin mais des gens qui
sont un peu déçus de la situation
actuelle souvent un peu d engageons donc
ils voudraient que les jours un milliard
ça c'est trop peu de points communs à ce
que moi tant par deux policiers pour
votre langue au lycée j'ai plus la
politique
tout est important et sexy mais quand on
va quand même que certains changements
qui ne peuvent se produire lorsque on
est jamais avoir vu l'animal maintenant
pas ça qui manque à ces commentaires ça
se démarque le stand salle je pense plus
à gauche que c'est à coup on est habitué
je vous demande aussi s'il vous plaît un
petit peu de discipline mais sans qu est
ce que les gens prenaient au sérieux
l'exercice qu'il voulait que la
proposition qui sortiront pas avant même
d'avoir fini ce processus de
consultation lors c'est à dire déjà nous
assistons fait pas quelques savait aussi
se terminer là je pense que ça sera déjà
une belle contribution
la démocratie québécoise mais fait
d'avoir simulé le des bop d'abord unis